Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how NVIDIA’s incredible
light transport algorithm can render these
notoriously difficult photorealistic smoke
plumes, volumetric bunnies, and even explosions
interactively.
We are going to talk about this amazing paper
in a moment, and given that NVIDIA can already
render this absolutely beautiful marbles demo
in real time, not only with real time light
transport, but also with our other favorite
around here, real time physics!
This is just to say that tech transfer is
happening here, the papers are real, the papers
that you see here really make it to real applications
that everyone can use at home.
Please note that they won’t say exactly
what tech is under the hood here, but looking
at their best light transport papers might
be a good starting point of what is to come
in the future.
Now, back to the intro.
What you are seeing here should not be possible
at all!
Why is that?
Well, when we use a light transport simulation
algorithm to create such an image, we get
a photorealistic image, but as you see, not
immediately.
Not even close.
It is a miracle of science that with this,
we can shoot millions and millions of light
rays into the scene to estimate how much light
is bouncing around, and initially, the inaccuracies
in our estimations show up as noise in these
images.
As we shoot more and more rays, this clears
up over time.
However, there are two problems.
One, this can take hours to finish.
And in the case of volumetric light transport,
these light rays can bounce, scatter, and
get absorbed inside a dense medium, in that
case, it takes much, much longer.
Not only hours, sometimes, even days.
Oh my goodness.
So, how did NVIDIA pull this off?
Well, they built on a previous technique of
theirs that is capable of rendering 3.4 million
light sources, and not just for one image,
but it can even handle animation.
Just look at all this beautiful footage.
Now it would be so great to have a variant
of this that works on volumetric effects,
such as explosions and smoke plumes, but of
course, anyone who has tried it before says
that there is no chance that those could run
interactively.
No chance at all.
Well, scientists at NVIDIA beg to differ.
Check this out.
This is a previous technique and it says 12
spp.
That means 12 samples per pixel, which is
more or less simulating 12 light rays for
each pixel of these images.
That is not a lot of information, so let’s
have a closer look at what this previous method
can do with that.
Well, there is still tons of noise, and it
flickers a lot when we rotate the camera around.
Well, I would say there is not much hope here,
we would need hundreds, maybe even thousands
of samples per pixel to get a clean image,
not 12.
And, look, it gets even worse.
What?
The new technique runs not thousands, not
hundreds, and not even 12 samples per pixel
in the same amount of time, but…really?
Can this be?
1 sample per pixel?
Can you do anything meaningful with that?
Well, hold on to your papers, and check this
out.
Wow, look at that!
It can do much better with just one ray per
pixel than the previous technique can do with
12.
That is absolutely incredible.
I really don’t know what to say.
And it works not just on this example, but
on many others as well.
This is so far ahead of the previous technique
that it seems like science fiction.
I absolutely love it.
However, yes I can hear you asking, Károly,
but these are still noisy, so why get so excited
for all these incomplete results?
Well, do you remember what we did with the
previous NVIDIA light transport paper?
We took these noisy inputs, and plugged them
into a denoising technique that is specifically
designed for light transport algorithms.
It tries to guess what is behind the noise.
And as you see, these can help a ton.
But you know, can they help so much that a
still noisy input, a meager 1 sample per pixel
can become usable?
Well, let’s have a look.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
The result is clearly not perfect, one light
ray per pixel can hardly give us a perfect
image, but after denoising, this is unreal.
We are almost there right away!
It has so much less flickering than the previous
technique with much more samples, and we are
experienced Fellow Scholars around here, so
let’s also check the amount of detail in
the image.
And…whoa!
There is no contest here.
This technique also pulls off all this wizardry
by trying to reuse information that is otherwise
typically thrown away.
For instance, with no reuse, we get this baseline
result, and if we reuse information from a
previous frame in the animation, we get this.
That is significantly better than the baseline.
If we reuse previous rays spatially, that
is also an improvement.
So are these different kinds of improvements?
Well, let’s add them together, and oh yes,
now this is what we are here for.
Look at how much more information there is
in this image.
So now, even these amazing volumetric scenes
can be rendered interactively?
I am out of words.
What a time to be alive!
And, if you feel inspired by these results,
I have a free Master-level course on light
transport where we write a full light simulation
program from scratch, and learn about physics,
the world around us, and more.
If you watch it, you will see the world differently.
That is free education for everyone, that’s
what I want.
So, the course is available free of charge
for everyone, no strings attached, check it
out
in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!